i'm
dear president vanderlaan
a very warm welcome to our esc plenary
thank you very much for doing us the
honor of being with us today
we highly appreciate both of you being
reliable partners and strong supporters
of the european economic and social
committee
mr president i know that you can stay
with us just for the first minutes of
the debate
but mr vice president sevkovitch will
stay until the end to react to members
remarks and questions
the topic of our debate is very
important what are the priorities for
recovery and i know madam president mr
vice president that the commission works
hard with both a short and a long-term
perspective today it is clear that
overcoming the ongoing pandemic remains
the most urgent issue
as you said yourself dear president you
can be proud
europe should not have achieved such a
good result as 77 of the adult
population fully vaccinated without the
commission's initiative and joint forces
in research purchase and rollout of the
vaccination
we also appreciate the fact that eu is
the biggest donor of vaccines in the
world with more than 350 million doses
given to countries around the world
at the same time we must not forget that
still many countries in the world
struggle accessing sufficient vaccines
we will not be safe here in europe until
the whole world is safe
yesterday dsc has started a campaign to
help eu institutions member states to
increase the vaccination rate through
information campaigns social media video
testimonies
because the vaccinations are without
doubt our best protection against the
pandemic
in your state of the union speech you
also indicate in long-term central
policy pillars for your commission like
the climate and digital initiatives that
we fully support through our opinions
also we fully support the approach to
develop new policies not only taking
into account what is needed for tomorrow
but the day after tomorrow
only decisions based on strategic
foresight allow as a future proof
policy
dear president of vice presidents the
motto of my presidency at du is united
for the future of europe and we need to
work together for europe that prosperous
economically socially inclusive and
environmentally sustainable
and we also need to make sure that
organized civil society thrive and live
excuse me in an open values-based
society
let's join forces to make europe a
really great place to be and to prosper
civil society organizations have a key
role to play in the context of the
conference on the future of europe and
the esc has strongly supported the idea
of the conference and we are doing our
best to collect the views of civil
society organizations and citizens in
every corner of the eu
we are convinced the conference is
crucial to establish a new emotional
link between the eu and its citizens and
develop a european narrative for the
21st century
in order to avoid fueling euroscepticism
we need to ensure a bottom-up process
reaching out to each and every corner of
the european union especially also to
those citizens that are still not
convinced or even opposed to the
european idea
we must convince them that europe
delivers a lot for their daily lives
we must also ensure that their ideas and
concerns raised during the conference
result in tangible results and concrete
follow-up measures are taken
before handing over to you i would like
to confirm the presidential vice
president that the esc will continue to
supporting you in the implementation of
the ambitious goals of the commission
and of its work program through good and
timely opinions and through our work
on a renewed protocol on cooperation in
order to further strengthen the current
excellent cooperation between our
institutions the president of floresias
[Applause]
good morning good morning to all of you
good to see you again
finally dear president
distinguished members
it is a great pleasure to finally
participate
in person
in one of your meetings again
it has been now for two years i think
that we have been
confronted with the crisis like
no other the pandemic
and through all these challenging months
very supportive
and
very convinced in your mission
you make
people's voice heard
you make the voices of civil society of
trade unions of business hurt
voices of small entrepreneurs of farmers
of consumers
but also of professional associations
voices of voices of our employees
and of self-employed
and through the years
the committee and the commission have
indeed established an excellent
cooperation
we are and we will remain closed
partners both in annual policy planning
and for the building of our long-term
vision
and as always your recommendations
provided a very important contribution
as you said madam president to our work
program 2022
we all want to speed up
the green and the digital transitions
and we want to preserve the foundations
of our social market economy economy and
i emphasize social because around the
world we have a lot of market economies
but we only have one unique european
social market economy
but let me first focus on the current
situation
at the moment being we are witnessing a
rapid resurgent of covet 19
unfortunately
and it has come along with increased
illness hospitalization and a high death
toll
all of which is unfortunately very much
concentrated among those who are not yet
vaccinated
and on top of this we are now faced with
a new variant omicron
we know that it is spreading fast
and we know that it is a variant of high
concern
but what is different is that compared
to a year ago
we have achieved now some crucial
breakthroughs
in how we fight the virus
we know that we need to protect
ourselves and our loved ones
those who are vaccinated are the most
protected from severe illness
it is not perfect but is the best
protection you can get today against the
virus whatever the variant is
and thanks to our eu vaccine strategy
there is no shortage of effective
vaccines
and thank you very much madam president
for having mentioned
what we do for
the rest of the world
but if i look at europe there is no
shortage of vaccines we have access
by the end of the year we will have a
manufacturing capacity here in europe
of over 300 million doses per month
and we have contracts in place as you
might recall to ensure that we can get
access
to adapted vaccines if this is necessary
so we are well prepared but again i have
to say it we have to step up the
vaccination rates across the european
union
and across all ages including young
people and children
and we need to accelerate the rollout of
boosters it's the three shots that are
necessary now
it is absolutely important
to have as many people not only
vaccinated but boosted so three shots
to protect themselves and to protect
others and we all know
what
the best protection against this virus
and its variants is
i really really count on you
to spread the message to all the
companies you represent to all the
organizations you represent
you make those organizations heard
please send back the message to your
organizations and to the trade unions
that we really join forces on this
important matter
at the same time we also tackle other
pressure pressing issues and madam
president you have mentioned them we
have forcefully engaged
in our green and digital transition
and let me concentrate on three issues
here
the first is
that we need affordable energy
and the green transition
that is crucial to have affordable
energy the second is supply chains
and the digital transition
and the third for a topic i want to
focus on is the future of work and
social dialogue
now to the first point
rising energy prices
rising energy prices concern all of us
they tell us that we are way too
dependent on gas we've seen at the last
weeks the rising energy prices is
because of the rising gas prices this is
not sustainable
we just have to know that 90 percent of
our gas is imported 90 percent
so europe's future energy security
clearly depends on clean homegrown
energy
while fossil fuels became more and more
expensive over the last years renewable
energy did not
this is the trend that we have seen and
this is an important trend thus
we are encouraging all member states if
we look at the high energy prices
to in the short run
support businesses and consumers
bring relief for example through state
aid and to cut energy taxes and bills
extensive work
is crucial there too to help us
we are also discussing a european
strategy on gas reserve and the
possibility of common
procurement
these are all measures that can help us
now and in the median term
and our position is not optimal because
as i said 90 percent of the gas is being
imported
but in the long run
the one and only way out of that is
invest in renewable energies to be
independent to have homegrown renewable
energies it's better for the climate
it's better for the people it's better
for our resilience and our independence
now we have the necessary funds to make
that also possible to make it a reality
let's have a look at next generation eu
our recovery plan and the eu budget
if you look at that we will invest
around about 500 billion euros in the
green transition
we will for example speed up
of course the development of renewable
energy in europe
at least 36 billion euros in national
recovery plans are precisely earmarked
for investment in clean hydrogen
in wind energy and in solar energy
over 50 billion euros will be
is earmarked for building renovations
and energy efficiency and you know that
we lose a lot of energy through
buildings heating and cooling
and i'm sure that you agree with me that
every euro spent
on renewables is not only good for the
planet but it's also an investment and
affordable energy of households and
businesses and it is an investment in
the resilience of our societies and
economies
we're striving for the same pioneering
role in digitalization
and this is my second point i've
recently visited asml
it is
a major player
in the global value chain for
semiconductors
you all know the semiconductors these
tiny little things
without semiconductors without those
chips there is no digital
they are in almost everything
and as everything is connected
we need for almost everything the
semiconductors the microchips
they are for example in our computers
and our smartphones and our cars in our
household appliances you name it in
everything
and therefore
the shortage that we experience right
now in semiconductors is really painful
and hurting our economy and our society
we know that european factories are
closing
because they cannot get enough chips
everything is there they could produce
the demand is there
but they have to close down because they
do not have the supply of chips that is
necessary
and this is certainly not sustainable
the present bottleneck and supply is a
hangover
and linked to the disruptions
caused by the pandemic because of the
pandemic we had a disruption of supply
chains and then we started to realize
how dependent we are on some critical
supply chains
but these disruptions in the supply
chains is also
only a symptom of a broader issue if you
look at the semiconductors and the
microchips
we are overly dependent
concerning semiconductors
on only a handful at most
of suppliers from asia
and this is why the commission is
proposing a european ships act
it is to scale up europe's high tech
chip ecosystem
again worldwide the demand for
microchips and semiconductors is
exploding
and we want to keep up so by 2030 the
number of connected devices just to give
you an idea globally could reach 200
billion
devices being connected
that means over 20 devices necessary
per person 20 devices per person are
connected and for that you need the
semiconductors and the microchips and
this gives you an idea how important
they are for our economic survival
our goal is
that we want to double the global market
share of european-made ships
from nowadays 10 percent
to then
20 30
20
we have to join forces to achieve this
we need to coordinate our research on
ships
we need to invest in the build-up of
manufacturing chips we need workers with
the right skills to be able to produce
the chips
and we need to coordinate the support
that member states give to companies
to step up their chips production so a
whole ecosystem that has to be built
raising demand raising supply at the
same time
including all the other crucial topics
that i have been
naming if we look at the numbers
up to 200 billion euros from next
generation eu
will go to digitalization including
research infrastructure and skills
so my small example of the tiny chips
is a big
lesson to learn about europe's
competitiveness
and about bolstering the resilience of
our single market
and this brings me to
the third point to jobs and skills in a
fair economy
and a fair recovery
as you know the pandemic has accelerated
changes
to the labor market rapidly
who should know it better than you
you have held public hearings on this
issue
you have held public hearings with a
focus on upskilling and reskilling
so you know the facts as well as i do
and i think we all have been speaking
since many many years about those topics
also what lifelong learning is concern
the green and the digital transformation
is coming along with a broad jobs
transformation too
and this is why we developed the pact
four skills
together with trade unions employees
associations
and in just one year
close to 500 organizations have pledged
to reskill
1.5 million people
working in key industrial areas
such as for example the automotive
sector
micro electronics i was just talking
about them or for example offshore wind
farms i was also talking about the
renewables so these are all topics we
very well know
with next generation eu
europe is also investing massively
in the green and the digital skills and
the lifelong learning
we see this everywhere in the union i
give you some example greece for example
is using the recovery funds to address
the skills
mismatch you know that problem that you
have some skills on one side but the
demand are for others
reconcile that
portugal is launching a program to
empower businesses to upskill and
reskill its workers in the company
itself
and finland is using for example next
generation eu to create personalized
and digital services for job seekers
just to be better in the match of the
labor market
next generation use thus providing the
investment to train european workers for
the next generation of jobs
and let me demonstrate how we want to
achieve this with three concrete
examples
they are based on proposals that we have
just presented either yesterday or are
about to present
there is first of all our proposal on
individual learning
accounts
and you know very well this idea it is
the core of lifelong learning
our idea is that every adult
should accumulate every year
a certain number of credits like an
electronic wallet
to invest in getting new skills
and this and this is important
regardless of whether you are employed a
worker or you are looking for work
or you are self-employed
every year
you can collect your credits your
potential
and then when it's time
you can invest
in pulling these credits to get
upskilling reskilling learning whatever
is necessary for your individual
situation
and we know that some countries already
provide these opportunities but we think
with this proposal we've put on the
table yesterday of the college
that lifelong learning should be a right
for all europeans so i'm very proud that
we made this step forward
the commission has also put forward
yesterday
a proposal for platform workers
we all know
the world of the work
is changing rapidly with the platforms
and i think it is very important that
yes we are adapting to a changing world
but we will never adapt our values the
values are universal
so we have to make sure that the
changing work world also works for our
values
because there is a promise
in europe that is bound to the social
market economy
and this promise
must remain the same
the promise is
we all work together
and we share the benefits
and for the great risks of life
we are collectively protected this is
basically the social market economy
so it is built on the question
to make us thrive in good times
and in times of crisis
and it helps workers
and business
to absorb better shocks because of this
collective protection of the big risks
of life
be it
age be it sickness be it unemployment
for example
and of course the social market economy
creates opportunities by promoting
innovation growth and fair competition
this is also part of the social market
economy
now new forms
of work must have
equal rights
and this is the proposal of yesterday
for the platform workers
first of all to define
and to make clear when they are
self-employed or employed at the
platform and with the employment at the
platform with the platform comes along
of course the investment and the social
security that is the hallmark of the
european union single market
and this brings me
to the role of social partners my last
most important point
if we want to get the recovery right
social dialogue must be
at the center
the commission has insisted that social
partners play a strong role
in the recovery and resilience plan
i know in some regions it was very
satisfactory
satisfactory in other regions not as
much i heard the positive remarks and i
heard the complaints yes but we will go
further
next year the commission is proposing a
council recommendation
calling for more social dialogue at
national level so we have to keep on
going to push hard for that topic i'm a
deep believer and supporter
of the social dialogue because i know by
experience through all those years how
beneficial it wasn't is
not only for our economy but also for
our society because this is where the
tailored good results are formed that
are a golden compromise to move forward
our social market economy
because their colleagues
distinguished members
the pandemic has taught us at least one
thing and that is
even against the hardest challenges
we have the power to shape our own
future
and this age calls for transformational
politics we're amidst of them right now
already
a european green deal
a digital decade for europe
and a new social rulebook for workers
and businesses
i would like to thank you
for your contribution
to the conference on the future of
europe
madam president you mentioned it
thank you so much you have the power
to mobilize voices from across the
continent
from all sectors of society
and with your support of course the
conference on the future of europe has a
much much broader reach
the conference on the future of europe
is i think the perfect platform again i
take that word for civil society to make
their voices heard and of course to
shape europe's future
because europe is in the very end what
we make out of it so i'm looking forward
to your cooperation which indeed
traditionally has been an excellent one
is an excellent one and i hope for the
future will stay an excellent one thank
you very much for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much to mrs presidents uh
we have now the chance to listen to the
three group presidents
again i stress please stick to the time
that you are given first one is the
president of group three mr sheamus
boland
okay
thank you very much president
president vanderlane and
commissioner shakovic you are extremely
welcome to this morning's
meeting and i want to complement
the fact that you are here talking to
civil society
talking to many organizations who really
do have an enormous amount of cohesion
and routing into the normal
ordinary lives of people during the
covert crisis civil society
organizations members of our group group
three
were found helping people at all levels
in society to accommodate and get used
to the uh restrictions that are still
there
i would like to complement you and the
commission
for making it very clear and for
achieving an equality of distribution of
vaccines that is the envy of the rest of
the world you are to be complimented for
that
i would like to comment on the fact that
you
clearly outlined some of the major
headings facing europe for example the
impending recovery
bearing in mind we have another crisis
on our horizons climate change
bearing in mind we have a major issue
and you mentioned this yourself leaving
nobody behind
that means the health recovery you
mentioned the health union i i'm going
to ask you straight what will be the
plans in order to achieve a proper
health union given what we have learned
from the current crisis you mentioned
the digital changes
and you mentioned the green and the
social economy and i really welcome the
fact that you emphasize the social
economy for our members and group tree
this is extremely welcome
just quickly on the health union
proposals we believe
if we have learned nothing from covert
price crisis
we must have a more robust health system
through your leadership and commission
you'd proved how we can manage it as
best we can
in terms of research in terms of
speeding the whole issue regarding
vaccination distributions but we have a
lot more to learn as we learned in
lisbon only last week
the amount of people suffering from
cancer and other massive diseases is
enormous and the only thing holding that
up is
research
finally can i ask you this
will you give us an answer in terms of
allowing social organizations like my
own in ireland and others to be part of
the discussions for recovery
thank you very much for being here this
morning
thank you very much seamus
now i have the president of group one
who's sitting over there stefano maria
thank
please
thank you madam president
i'm sitting here thank you adam
president
yeah
okay thank you thank you madam president
for finding the time to address us today
it is indeed encouraging to hear how
much you value civil society and social
dialogue although i must admit that that
it is a pity that your schedule does not
allow you enough time today to engage in
a debate with all of us
i have one specific comment and two very
specific questions first and foremost
congratulations for the vaccine rollout
probably the best vaccine rollout in the
world especially when one considers that
we are have sent over 1 billion doses to
over 150 countries
more doses than have been administered
in the eu itself
the fact that we have been successful in
developing vaccines is also testimony of
our innovative capacity and our strong
intellectual property legislation which
we must continue to preserve
my first question concerns international
trade i'm sure you agree that the common
eu trade policy plays a key role in
strengthening our position in a global
economy
however the eu 27 have not yet found
consensus on the new eu trade strategy
launched by the commission in february
my question is
is there a growing risk that the eu will
lose its potential as a strong actor in
trade policy and what will your
commission do to try and unlock the
current situation my second question
concerns competitiveness there is no
doubt that one of the aspects
characterizing this commission is the
drive to introduce more and more
legislation at an eu level i am sure you
will not be surprised if i say that the
business community is somewhat weary of
this approach
my question to you madam president is
beyond the occasional impact assessment
does the commission have any plans to
introduce a competitiveness check
whether the constant flow of new
legislation being proposed is now
negatively is not negatively impacting
our international competitiveness
especially
thank you very much
unfortunately also the rules faster
well it's for everybody now um
now over to oliver repke president of
group two
thank you chair
your president van der lion and vice
president chefchaouich
thank you for joining us today
and thank you for these very brave words
and for the very welcome announcement
with respect to the implementation of
the social pillar
i just have one point
i think we all need to be grateful that
europe despite the initial difficulties
has been able to work together to fight
the covet epidemic or pandemic
we really
should be pleased that we were able to
develop vaccines that were able to
ensure the proper procurement and
distribution of them
i agree it's a huge success
as trade unions we have always been in
favor of
quick action being taken by the
commission to respond to the crisis and
our citizens or to protect our citizens
our workers
and our businesses but not just in
europe globally there are huge gaps
still in access to covid vaccination
despite the kovacs initiative now i'm
sure this current wave will not be the
last
as long as we here and worldwide do not
have
are not safe from covid then we will not
be safe from the pandemic so my appeal
to you is that
we need to ensure that you as the
commission take action have an open
debate at the eu level and consider
a possible temporary suspension of
patent rights on vaccine this is what's
known as the trips waiver at the wto
level it could possibly help poorer
countries have broader access to
vaccines
this shouldn't be an obligation
it's a wto agreement that would only
allow those countries that would have
the possibility of using the waiver
could invoke it we should at least have
the opportunity to discuss
whether such a waiver would be an option
to increase
production capacities we know production
company countries such as the us are in
favor of such a waiver so
thank you once again president for your
excellent management of the crisis and
thank you for joining us here today
president would like to react
very briefly to the last point
i
am about
to leave i just want to take the
opportunity on this very important topic
on the vaccines overall just to share
some figures with you
so indeed
we have delivered now to the european
people around about 1 billion doses of
vaccines
and as it was said
1.4 billion doses
have so far been exported
to 150 countries in the world
we are the only region worldwide
that stayed open throughout the whole
pandemic what export is concerned
and you remember under huge pressure at
the beginning when we had really trouble
to scale up
so we can be really proud of that and
this
of course deepened the trust and the
confidence
of the business sector
to be here and to invest in the european
union because they could rely on the
fact that we stay fair and keep open um
for export this is expert
then we have a second point that is
donations thank you for mentioning that
indeed if you look at the numbers
of donations given now i'm not speaking
about pledges because pledges are
important but they are promises for the
future like till the end of next year
we're going to give y z numbers of doses
what is more important right now is what
has really been given already physically
given
and there with by now it's 370 million
doses of vaccines
the european union is world leading in
giving those doses
we have a discrepancy that covax now
has to move on to proceed these doses to
the receiving countries and that there
are difficulties not only on carboxide
but sometimes also in the for example
logistic in the receiving countries or
infrastructure is not there syringes
cooling chain you name it
so there are
obstacles there but still the european
uh union is
the largest funder um of donations um by
given the vaccines given now
then we do something
and this comes to your question of the
trip's waiver i think the trips waiver
if you just waive ip rights
you don't transfer any kind of knowledge
to the other regions of the world the
only risk you have is that some
just take your intellectual property and
build on that vaccines in a way that we
have not wanted we want for example the
manufacturing of vaccines going to the
african continent and therefore our
proposal is in wto to have a compulsory
licensing in a pandemic
so that a company is forced to license
at
very very low costs
thus you can not only
give knowledge but really transfer the
technology to another region and we do
something on top and i think this is the
most important
together as to team europe with our
member states
we are investing with biontech
on the african countries with our
african partners
and private companies to build up
manufacturing hubs for mrna technology
and this is of course nothing for the
short term but for the mid and long term
this makes sure we bring it to senegal
we are right now building it up in
rwanda and in south africa
and as the mrna technologies are so
promising not only for vaccines against
covet but potentially tuberculosis
potentially malaria and more people die
of tuberculosis and malaria in africa
than of covet 19
this is a big step forward and there i
think this is an investment that is
really added value and sustainable for
the future just wanted to say that at
the very end many many many thanks for
your support and all these topics
because we have not forgotten a year
ago this time we had zero vaccines
and yes we went through very difficult
starting times
but we stayed together
i mean just imagine two or three member
states would have gotten their own
unilateral contracts
and the rest none this would had would
have torn apart the european union so i
really want to thank you also that you
stood with us in the most difficult
times this is something we will never
forget and this really really helped so
many thanks for that
and um
thank you for having had me here today
[Applause]
dear colleagues
we continue with the debate and the next
speaker on my list is mrs marion
miss marion please press the speak
button
hello can you hear me dear madam
everybody hello from zagreb in the last
two years a commission heaven profiles
that children and youth are
priorities which i fully support
especially youth guarantee child
guarantee and alma program i came from
croatia and represent ngozhomisely which
deals with young people in croatia
demography is one of the largest youth
problem
we are just about entering eu year of
youth how does the commission plan to
take a huge demographic issue and brain
drain that is act accurately affecting
to many of eu regions and our member
states which initiative instrument and
eu funds incline inclining partnership
which institutional philanthropy
organization do you have in plan
thank you and you can count on us from
civil society for the support and i hope
the president will keep us in our speech
next time in future thank you
thank you very much for partying
please
thank you very much
i'm going to be speaking german
the vice president at the beginning of
the legislature you um received um
from the highest uh well you you ended
up on the very highest political level
um the strategic foresight was uh rubber
stamped and the committee here has the
um twice has um looked at the
commission's report
and we are
convinced that the strategic foresight
is very much uh part and parcel of
policy and we would like to thank you
for using this methodology but we were
disappointed that in the second report
the current one
the strategic foresight isn't um
complete and it remains unclear
how
um in the european semester or in other
relevant european political processes um
how this is uh how this is anchored and
what influence this has so it's very
it's open
um
as to the um orientation or the guidance
so that the strategic foresight will
provide moving forward in europe at the
same time we're dealing with many
different issues decarbonization
digitalization demographic change
deglobalization the commission president
has mentioned those issues people expect
and quite rightly so that political um
decision makers
have a grip on these omega trends but
also have a coherent and strategic plan
as to how to deal with them against this
background it's disappointing that for
instance the role of social
insurance systems and their current uh
front and future um
financing um isn't uh fully factored in
here
we believe this phrygic force is a very
important instrument and we would like
to make sure that it is used
appropriately so we are calling on you
all of us here in the esc um to
really shine a light on how important
that csos are and
how important it is that we have a
knowledge fed in to this whole process
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much chair i'm in the
room
i wanted to chip in on an issue which it
wasn't uh broached by the commission
president but it's a dear to
the future french the french president
and then that is uh europe's uh the
defense role and the strategic compass
if you look
here i am
we had the uni uh lateral um
uh issue we know that to the us of
august we know that the u.s is looking
more at the pacific more than northern
europe and so um there's a certain issue
um
at stake here so we believe that
european defense is not a contradiction
to nato no it strengthens nato so we're
talking about creating a rapid
intervention force or five uh a hundred
uh people five five thousand five
thousand to ten thousand um
strong
what
criteria for mobilization and
intervention will there be so
if
i would just like to recall what uh
stalin said or about the the pope
europe how many divisions thank you
schwartz please
dear colleagues
the vice president good morning to each
and every one of you
in your portfolio of responsibilities
you need to have a a vision of the
european union moving forward and
we have great expectations here as csos
within this committee
we are always consulted by institutions
such as yours especially on legislative
proposals
your 2022 work program is very
interesting
looking at the digital and green
transitions
as well as the recovery plan to get us
out of the covert 19
crisis we also need
member states to respect european law
and implement it
so
what are you going to do
on this score during the year 2022 thank
you
merciful thank you very much mr de lotto
please
thank you very much chair
i would like to welcome
vice president javakovic
this is pretty much your second home
i very briefly would like
to
broach a few issues
the
ecosystem that's necessary for for
companies for workers for consumers
for citizens in general
in terms of dealing with the dual
challenges of the of energy and
digital
it's
clear
that
strategic autonomy is key here
as is competitiveness and joint rules
open to commerce but with a strong
european dimension i'm thinking about
strategic raw materials batteries
semiconductors and many other issues
in the ccmi
we are working at the link between space
civil civilian industry
and and military
uh senor palmieri mr palmieri please
yes thank you very much
first of all i would very much like to
thank the commission
for in its work program having taken on
board many of the issues that were put
forward in our resolution
next year
as has been said there'll be the
revision of the economic governance of
the stability and growth pact
and you have opened the public
consultation on that
what we hope is that there will be a
true reform
we very much appreciate
that even though we're going through one
of the worst crises in the union's
history you have um
triggered the safeguard clause in that
pact
we hope that this will be maintained
until
we can bring about a reform of the
economic governance
and when there will be a real reduction
in
unemployment in europe
and that there will be a stable level of
growth with the introduction of the new
budget
measures
what we want here is a real change
towards a
revised and rebalanced governance
structure which ensures that we meet the
same priorities inclusive growth full
employment
dignified work a
social market economy which is
competitive with stable public finances
and this framework will enable us to
avoid the emergence of asym asymmetries
between member states or even within
member states and it will also stimulate
investment through the application of
the golden rule on public investments so
as they
do not contaminate
the um
[Music]
lead to greater public date or
get in the way of us in our digital and
green transitions thank you very much
president
all the best
mr commissioner when we are talking
about the future of europe we have to be
aware that the future will be shaped not
only by the politicians and institutions
but also by millions of ordinary
citizens volunteers acting every time
out of their hearts in solidarity for
the common good
yesterday we adopted the ethiopian
volunteer citizens building the future
of europe as within last 10 years the
issue of volunteering has been gradually
disappearing from the european agenda
also considering that about 25 percent
of u.s citizens with no serious
difference between age group
are involved in volunteering every year
we call on european commission to take
re-election to declare 2025 the european
year of volunteers we believe that it
will be not only the way of paying
tribute to the millions of volunteers
also involved in coveted time but first
of all as the starting point for the
real eu policy in this area thank you
thank you very much mrs hartman radova
thank you very much
europe is at the turning point uh we
need to remain competitive enhance
international cooperation have a
rules-based international trade network
and a functioning single market
we need stronger links between the
fundamental single market freedoms and
actions for acceleration of the trend
transitions as well as an investment
conducive regulatory framework
we must avoid putting any extra burden
on companies shoulders in this very
difficult situation but also remove
remaining barriers
i strongly support the pet regulation
agenda and call for strong dialogue with
stakeholders
high quality impact assessments as well
as respective measures in the commission
work programs to address every single uh
barrier listed in the annual single
market reports i also trust you will
succeed with the one in